okay so we've we've seen how to compute
the first principal component and and
the description was that it provides a
you know a summary of the of the data
it's got the most variance
well you can go further if you've got
p variables you can now ask for a
second principal component
which also has large variance but
unless you want to get the same one as
the first you have to put some
constraints so the constraint the
natural constraint is that this
second variable be uncorrelated with the
first so it's going to tell you
different information about the data
and subject to being uncorrelated it's
going to have large variance largest
variance okay so that's that's a problem
which we can phrase in pretty much the
same way it's going to be a linear
combination we've got it now indexed by
2 instead of 1 there's a sub 2 there
and
and subject to that constraint of being
uncorrelated we wanted to to maximize
the variance
now
there's some interesting math that comes
with this it turns out that being
uncorrelated also means that the alphas
the fees are bigger pardon that define
the principal component
as as vectors right those are the
loading vectors so the fees for the
second component
defines a vector that's orthogonal to
the fees for the first component so it's
just a property of of the solution
and so we can characterize that
lack of correlation as orthogonality of
the fees
and the solution turns out also comes
from the singular value decomposition of
x so the second principal components
defined by the second right singular
vectors and there's going to be a third
component a fourth component and so on
that's that
sequentially maximized variance subject
to being uncorrelated with all the
previous ones
and it turns out that you can have it
most
n minus one or p principle components so
n is the number of data points sometimes
p is bigger than n
and if that's a case then we're
restricted by n but otherwise we just
restricted by p the number of variables
so
we get a complete decomposition
of the data matrix in terms of its
principal components
so as an illustration we're going to
show you an example using some data on
usa arrests so for each of the 50 states
in the united states
we've got the number of arrests per 100
000 residents for each of three crimes
assault murder and rape and we also have
measured the urban population the
percentage of the population in each
state living in urban areas
so there's
50 observations so each of the principal
components are going to be n vectors
with length 50 because they derived
their new variables
and we'll get at most
four
principal components and each of them
will be described in terms of loading
vectors of of length p equals four
in this case we actually standardize the
variables before we did the principal
components to have mean zero and
standard deviation one
that's that's a fairly standard practice
and we'll get back to that in a moment
but let's first look at the results
so here's the results this picture is
called a biplot
and it's a way of displaying the
principal components and the loadings in
in a single plot
so each of the blue
well they're not points but marks on the
picture is is a state and so their names
are there
the origin is at the center over here so
everything's been centered with respect
to the origin
and
on the plot as well
what we see are the loading vectors so
this plot is the plot of the first
principal component along the horizontal
axis here
and the second principal component on
the vertical axis so we plot the first
two principal components which is fairly
standard because you know those are the
most two important
ones and
and so
in order to understand the principal
component so each each observation which
is a state has a score on the principal
component
and so some are large and positive and
some are negative
and then to understand these scores we
look at the loadings
and so the loadings are plotted as
vectors here because they we've got for
each
variable we got its loading on the first
principal component and the second
principal component so that allows us to
plot it as a vector in this space
and what we read from this is that the
first principal component
has got
positive loadings large positive
loadings on rape assault and murder
so all of the the crimes are positive
loadings on the first principle
component
so that tells us that this direction on
the positive side is
loaded up on all three crimes so roughly
about the same amount
okay
and so this is a these are going to be
high crime regions these are going to be
low crime regions
and so now you can look at where the
states lie for example florida is
sitting right out on the first principle
component so that's a high crime area
and and so on so you look at the
positions where
where states project to see how they
relate to the principle component
now the second principle component seems
to get
largely loaded on on urban population so
this is a high urban population this is
low urban population
and you can even interpret things like
rape seems to be on the positive side in
higher urban populations
than in low urban populations
so that again this biplot is a picture
that lets you
both display the first two principal
components and also display the loadings
and give you a way of interpreting the
picture so
what does it mean for like a component
minus three what is that well minus
three means that you low down the actual
units are somewhat standardized units
but it means you on the negative scale
in the crime rate so these are low crime
areas and so some of the extreme low cri
climb areas are
if i can read the text there's main is a
low crime area new hampshire iowa yeah
okay so here's some details that explain
the the figure which we've just gone
through you can read it in your own time
um it's customary also to produce a
table of the loadings and and so this
just summarizes what we saw in the
picture so we see that that
in the first principal component pretty
much equal loadings on on murder assault
and rape
whereas urban population has somewhat of
a lower loading is the second principle
component
urban population's got a high loading
and
murder's got quite a high loading as
well so oh no that's a negative loading
and but but rape was a slightly positive
loaded
so you can actually look at the numbers
but it's often better and more useful to
look at them graphically
okay
so that's a primary use of principal
components to come up with summaries of
the data that explain mostly what's
going on but there's another preview of
principal components and that's in terms
of approximating a cloud of data by a
low dimensional hyperplane
and it turns out these two views
are equivalent to each other
so here's a data set it's it's an
artificial data set in the left-hand
plot
we see some points they
meant to be visualizing them in
three-dimensional space
and
what we've shown you is a
two-dimensional hyperplane that's meant
to approximate those points
now the points are colored but that's
just
to help us
explain what's going on this seems to be
like a clustering but
what we see is that this hyperplane sort
of passes through the middle of these
points and we asking for a hyperplane
that makes
that gets as close as possible to the
points and what we mean by that is that
if we take each point and and compute
the shortest distance to the hyperplane
and sum the squares of those distances
we want the hyperplane that gets closest
to the the data in that sense
and it turns out that the hyperplanes
defined in terms of the two largest
principal components
in other words the direction vectors
that define the hyperplane if you think
of having two direction vectors
in the hyperplane
it'll be orthogonal to each other those
are also the two direction vectors of
the largest two principal components
and it sort of makes sense getting
closer that we've got three been three
dimensions here so we've got three
variables
to get closest to the data
to find the plane closest to the points
we're asking actually that the
projection of the points in the plane
are spread out as much as possible
that'll be a characteristic of the
solution
in other words spread out means as much
variance as possible so let's give you
an intuition of why the two principal
components also characterize a solution
now i'm confused here what you described
about being close to points sounds to me
like least squares regression which we
covered earlier so it's a different
somehow yeah that's a good that's a good
question rob least squares regression is
also find in a hyper plane that gets
close to the daily in some sense but
their closest is defined just in terms
of distance from the hyperplane to y the
response which was the supervising
variable but here we don't have any y
so here it's shortest distance
of the hyper plane to to the x's
themselves could you draw a picture into
a
scatter plot to show this
did i draw a scatter plot to show this
so the distinction between those two
okay so
for linear regression we have y
and well i can only draw one x maybe i
can do a second x in the picture so
that's x two x one
this is x one and we got a whole lot of
points
and now we find a hyperplane
okay
but in linear regression we focus in
just on this distance over here which is
not
perpendicular to the hyperplane
it's just distance in the y in the y
direction
right whereas in principle components
here
there's no special variable that's a y
and so we define distance in terms of
the perpendicular distance to the
hyperplane right how's that picture
a lot better than i could have done but
okay
all right
so this this slide here just describes
what we we've just gone through in
detail
now i deferred this point scaling of the
variable matters so here's our first two
principal components in our biplot
again
but this was computed when we
standardized each of the variables to
have unit variance what if we didn't do
that
well you get a very different picture
then
yeah
the
the um
the picture the first principle
component seems to be mostly assault
well it turns out that the variable
assault
had by far a much bigger variance in the
in the original data set than any of the
other variables
it's just the units in in which it was
measured
and and so it just dominates the first
principle component
and you know if you have variables that
are actually measured in different units
it's quite easy to have one variable
that just
on its own has a way bigger variance
than the rest and it will dominate the
principal components
so if you want to avoid the the effect
of units and or just individual
variables having a big variance then you
standardize the variables
and
in that case what you're dealing with
is is variables all measured on it on an
equal scale and now you can really see
um
which which components
add together to give you large variance
so
there's also associated with principal
components a decomposition of variance
so we start off we've got our variables
and we can we can
talk about the total variance that's
about to be explained which is the sum
of the variance of all the variables
okay and if the variables have been
centered to have mean zero that's given
by this expression over here one over n
summation x i j squared is just going to
be this is going to be the variance of
the jth variable and we sum that over
the p variables
and the variance of the
of the nth principle component
is going to be the sum of the z i m
squared again the the z i's
are going to have mean 0 because the
original x's at mean 0 they'll inherit
that property as well so this is an
expression for the variance of the nth
principal component okay
now it can be you can show that the the
sum of the variances of all the x's is
the same as the sum of the variances of
all the z's
that's just a mathematical property
and so
we can talk about the proportion of
variance explained by looking at the
variance of an individual z relative to
the the sum of the variances and that's
gives you an idea of the importance of
of each of the components
okay
so
um and that'll be a quantity that's
between zero and one
right because the sum of the the the
variance of the z's um
is in the denominator
okay so this left plot on on the on the
crime data shows the proportion of
variance explained by each of the
principal components so the first one
explains about point six of the variance
or sixty percent of the variance
the second component explains just over
twenty percent of the variance and so on
so these necessarily
necessarily decrease
because
after all we've been asking the first
principle component to explain the most
of the variance the second one has to be
uncorrelated with the first
and so they these necessarily have to go
down and sometimes we plot
the cumulative percentage of variance
explained
which is in this case it's the this is
the percentage of the first
principal component of the total
variance this is the percentage of the
first two and so on
and the idea is
that we want to know basically when to
stop how many components we need
and so we're going to be happy to stop
if we've explained most of the variance
so if we've let's say the first two
principal components explain 95 of the
variance we'd be happy to stop there yet
it looks like we need the first three
principal components
because there's no real hard and fast
rules on how many components you need so
this percentage variance explained is a
one way of sort of getting a feeling of
when you've got most of the the variance
explained
um so that that the the question that
just come up is how many components
should we use and so there's no real
simple answer
and one thing you might think is why not
use cross-validation is is that
available for this purpose
well it's not really
and you might think why not
we use cross-validation in regression it
was very useful there
well
we don't have a response here
cross-validation was used when we had a
response and we could see how well we
were predicting the response when we
left some data out but we don't have a
response here so there's no supervising
variable to help us
so does that mean cross validation is
completely ruled out well not really one
of the uses of principal components
which we touched on earlier in this
course was in regression when you had a
lot of variables you could use principal
components to reduce the data to
a few important variables
i.e the first few principal components
and use them in the regression instead
well now you can use cross validation
because we do have a response in that
case
and so you might decide how many
principal components you need to use in
the regression and you could use
principal co you could use cross
validation to help you decide that but
there you have a supervising response
and
as as i mentioned in the in the previous
slide
um that's sometimes called a scree plot
and you can look for an elbow in the
scree plot so if you're
which is the percent variance explain
plot right so if your percent variance
explained looked like this if this was 1
and this was zero and if if the first
one was up there the second one was over
there and then the rest were all down
here
you'd say well two principal component
seems to be explaining a lot because
there's a big elbow here so if you look
for elbows in the scree plot that's
often are often helpful
so
that's the end of principle components
again principal components one of the
most useful tools we have in applied
statistics it's used all over the place
and it's got many other applications as
well which which we won't touch on yet
so it's a very useful tool
in the next session we're going to talk
about
the second most useful tool or another
very important tool which is clustering
and we'll tell you about two different
methods for clustering